ashes qui habite au nouveau brunswick
part en voyage pour enfin voir les
rocheuses
mais arrivé à destination il apprend que
sa valise est porté disparu
la compagnie aérienne fait des démarches
pour la retrouver mais achille et
frustré au lieu de skier il doit
magazine et il n'a même pas une brosse à
dents toujours sans nouvelles de ses
bagages il voit sa facture grimper et se
demande s'il sera remboursé achille la
réponse c'est oui
depuis juillet dernier le règlement sur
la protection des passagers aériens
qu'on appelle simplement la charte des
voyageurs prévoit que les transporteurs
aériens sont responsables des bagages
endommagés ou perdus mais aussi des
dépenses liées aux bagages retardée
jusqu'à un maximum d'environ 2100 $ par
passage est de retour chez lui on lui
annonce que sa valise
enfin été retrouvé mais achille concerne
quand même le droit de réclamer ce qu'il
a acheté pendant son voyage il a trois
semaines à partir du jour où on a
retrouvé sa valise pour faire sa
réclamation
le fin mot de l'histoire vous pouvez
voyager l'esprit léger
si vous en perdez des boues vous pourrez
être remboursés